how do you hope the war ends in Ukraine
well
I mean I I do hope and you know with a
ceasefire negotiated solution but it has
to be with Russia compromising on
something and that's not where we are
right now do you think both sides may be
willing to compromise most wars always
end in that way I mean nobody's ever
happy but they don't seem to either side
like legitimately doesn't want to
compromise right now yeah because
something like the thing is that for
Ukraine right now anything is a
compromise at his expense right yeah
yeah fast devastation
unbelievable casualty rates
biggest Refugee crisis since World War
II Russia's just said sorry this is our
territories not just Crimea I think
there could have been a negotiation over
there
but you know done yet I mean we've got
all kinds of formulas we've had all the
way through history of you know putting
things under a kind of guardianship
receivership of territory the United
Nations all kinds of different ways of
formulating that we could have easily
been creative but Russia's basically
saying no sorry we've taken this and any
other no negotiations just you
recognizing this for us not doing more
destruction I mean that is not the basis
for negotiation
and you know having you know kind of
people come and just sort of laying
those terms down is not a starting
position
I think Russia
is also you know in a in a dilemma of
its own making now because Putin has
made it very difficult you know to
compromise just by everything that he
said
now for Ukraine they've already won
a great moral political and Military
victory
it's just hard to see it right at the
particular moment they've done what the
Finns did in the winter War which the
Finns were devastated by the winter War
as well but they pushed them back now
the fins lost a lot of territory there's
corellia and you know huge space of
territory but
they got to be Finland
and you know now they're you know
joining NATO but they've been part of
the EU the question is how to
you know get Ukraine to be
Ukraine in a success
but you know is and that's the challenge
now again they've already won
psychologically politically militarily
because Putin doesn't
succeeded in what he wanted to do but he
has succeeded in completely and utterly
devastating them and this is the kind of
the old muscovite
the old Russian imperial old server
mentality you know going all the way
back to when the muscovites were the bag
men for the you know the horde the for
the Mongols it was destruction you know
you don't play with us we'll destroy you
know people talk about it as Mafia but
it's older you know all you have to go
does you go and see tarkovsky's Andre
Rubio I mean I remember you know seeing
that film when I was first as a student
in Moscow and just being whoa this is so
brutal
I mean this is just unremittingly brutal
because the whole point is
that you show people who's the Boss
the destruction is the point of things
as well because
you know you are emphasizing your
domination
and that's what Putin is doing right now
is saying okay you want to go in a
different direction so be it but I'm
Gonna Make You Suffer remember when
hodokowsky got out of
um the penal colony when Putin let him
out eventually he said he suffered
enough
but he suffered for 10 11 years
I don't think Putin feels that Ukraine
has suffered enough at this point or we
have suffered there's a part of this
Invasion that's punishment for something
yeah it's medieval
I mean look we're all capable of the
same things right there was a lot of
Destruction and that's what Assad was
like in Syria like his father
who destroy because you teach him a
lesson
and look Britain did that in the
colonial era I mean all the history of
British colonialism is exactly the same
you know up until recent times brutality
teaching people you know give teaching
them a lesson you have to suffer the US
did it I mean we did it with the Native
Americans you know we did it all over
the place you know as well this is kind
of what big you know states do
at different points in history just that
you know Russia's not moved on from that
I mean we've learned some lessons late I
hope you know we're fully internalized
them of you know things that we've done
you know kind of past the United States
we ideally are trying to do better and
most of Europe's trying to do better as
well think about France in Algeria you
know again you know we can see this in
many different settings
but I think you know for Putin right now
he hasn't taught all of us sufficient a
lesson
I just I talked to hundreds of people in
Ukraine and um
the tough thing
they're inspiring things that there's a
Unity the tough thing is
a lot of them speak intensely of hate
towards not just Russia but Russians
Russians that's how Europeans felt about
Germany and Germans at the end of World
War II
and uh generational hate like well I
don't think that hate is gonna pass well
it might it might well take a generation
I mean I won when I was a kid in the 70s
I went on exchanges to Germany
and that was like you know 30 years more
than 30 years after the end of the war
my grandfather had fought in World War
One or wouldn't speak to my parents when
they sent me on a
um then we hadn't thought World War II
we fought World War one he hated the
Germans
and he and he did not want me going you
know to Germany as an ex-gen student he
refused to meet you know kind of the
German kid who you know came to stay at
my house you know for example I mean it
takes a long time to and it takes a long
time to get over that but but you do I
mean and we have we have in Europe and
that was the whole point
of you know all that kind of exercise of
European Unity after World War II now
the big challenge is
what do we do with Russia because a lot
of people are talking now we can't have
European security without Russia that
people are saying we can't have a Europe
you know kind of with Russia
you know so how do we deal with this we
we've got to basically kind of it's
gonna be like Japan and Germany after
World War II after this just the level
of the atrocities that have been carried
out as you said the level of hatred
but we found a way of doing it
now it a lot of it will require change
on the part of Russia as well and
Russians and really thinking about this
I mean Gorbachev before tried to do in
the late 1980s with the black spots in
with glasses with openness and talking
about Russian history just kind of never
sort of withered on the vine as time
went on
what gives you hope about the future
well my hope comes into the fact that
we've done things before that we've got
ourselves out of tough times and we've
overcome stuff and in people because I
meet amazing people you just talked
about hundreds of people that you've met
with in Ukraine
and you know people all think
differently contexts and circumstances
change and people can evolve some people
get stuck Putin's got stuck but people
can evolve
and you know I do think that if we all
pull together and we've seen this in so
many contexts we can find solutions to
things just like we get back again to
our discussion about scientists and just
the kind of amazing breakthroughs of
you know what we did on covid or done on
you know kind of other you know diseases
and things and look there there is some
similarities there's a pathology around
war and conflict
years ago in the 1990s I worked on you
know a lot of the projects that were
funded by the Carnegie Corporation of
the United States under the then
presidency of David Hamburg who was a
scientist and actually did see a lot of
parallels between the sort of like the
pathology of disease and you know kind
of the the
pestilence you know of conflict kind of
idea and of course these you know
parallels had to be very careful because
you know they're not neat but there was
kind of like an idea in there and how do
you sort of treat this how do you deal
with this
and we did come up with all kinds of of
ideas and you know things that are still
out there we've created institutions
that have helped to keep the peace we
just have neglected them allowed them to
degrade just like the United Nations and
you know we've created problems inside
of them like the veto power of the
permanent powers on the
un Security Council but we can change
that he's just going to have a will and
I do think out there there are
sufficient people with a will and we've
just got to get people mobilized I mean
I'm always amazed by how people can
mobilize themselves around a crisis
remember Winston Churchill I don't quite
all the time because I can never
remember half his quotes but I do
remember the one about never let a good
crisis go to waste and I always think
that that you know yeah that we should
we shouldn't let this crisis go to waste
and something else can come out of this
just like in Ukraine like we've worried
before about corruption in Ukraine the
influence of the oligarchs we've got to
run oligarchs here in the US we need to
you know deal with as well but this is a
chance to do it differently
yeah it really is a chance to do things
differently and a part of that is young
people I have to ask you at least young
people I mean I'm feeling a bit on the
older side now but I still feel I've got
you know a bit of you know kind of Youth
within me at 57 I'm not that old but I'm
not that young but we have to work
together with younger and older people
come together in coalitions of you know
across Generations you remind me of of
uh kids who just graduated college and
say and I I'm I feel old
so yeah no I don't actually feel old but
it is a number Edge and you know when
you know you kind of think about when I
was I thought you don't like math yeah
like things like that yeah but I find it
interesting but you know when I was I
remember when I was a little kid I kept
thinking about the year 2000 and I
thought oh my God I'll be dead I'll be
35.
22 years ago